so as most of you know I recently quit
my job as a data scientist and I'm
trying to get into sweet and for sweet
if you want to get into sweet you have
to do these coding interviews and these
coding interviews they're not supposed
to test you if you know how to code or
if you're good at software engineering
they don't care about that like coding
is basically pure intelligence they're
testing your pure intelligence your IQ
you don't actually care if you can do
the actual job or if they think that you
can do you know build their
infrastructure what they care about is
if you could like reverse a linked list
or solve any of those coding problems
and I want to stress that these coding
problems are just IQ tests they're not
meant to show them how good you are at
building infrastructure or anything so I
just want to tell people who aren't
initiated in this suite interview
process just so that you guys get some
context like basically someone with no
software engineering skills can pass
these interviews because it's kind of
like a math test you know and I'm trying
to do that anyways I have to wake up and
I didn't think of a transition but
here's an ad before we continue I just
want to say that this video is sponsored
by Skillshare now they have a great
promote going on if you sign up using
the link on the description because they
will give you two months of premium for
free and here's a little secret most
courses on there you could definitely
finish in less than two months
Premium Membership gives you access to
all their classes and communities you
can learn anything from design business
coding and even data science Skillshare
is the perfect place to keep your mind
fresh and keep growing by learning a ton
perfect for your new year goals now 2019
is a year of growth and Skillshare is a
perfect place to do that
Skillshare is super affordable with an
annual subscription of less than $10 so
I took a couple of classes and I was
pleasantly surprised by one of their
it's actually data science class taught
by Frank Cain and oh he's a X Amazon
employee and it was pretty pretty good
like I was very very impressed because
the thing that's great about his class
was it was actually fully comprehensive
it taught you from the basics of like
Python to teaching how to do linear
regression to like k-means clustering it
teaches you everything unlike you know a
lot of other data science classes where
they're just kind of like vague and
they're just talking about certain
things
this one actually teaches you step by
step on how to become a data scientist
it's basically what data signs bootcamps
teach you and you can learn all of that
using that course which is really good
anyways the first 500 people to click on
the link in the description will get two
months of premium membership for free
and then you could take any classes you
want so check it out yank in case you
don't know what I did I I snapped my
fingers at my facial hair went away
wait let me show you see facial hair I
know is clean literally the only reason
I shave is for this video because I
haven't stepped outside in like weeks so
as I was saying I'm basically decoding
all day every day by the way I just want
to say maybe not a really good idea to
quit your job before getting an offer so
so yeah don't do what I did because like
the unemployment life you know it's
killing me you know I'm so disgusting
and unmotivated you know it's just like
I feel like basically just really hard
to motivate yourself well you know have
a job so wake up a like 1:00 p.m.
nowadays like holy [ __ ]
it really Sean's my day right and then
all I do is try to solve these coding
interviews and holy crap n they're
getting really hard nowadays yeah I
procrastinate like a lot and I don't
even
I'd open wear proper clothes anymore
because
you know I don't need to go out and I
start doing like really weird [ __ ] oh
[Music]
and I have to cook for myself now
because from all these years working for
Fang companies you just become a
man-child
you know I'm a big man child I have no
idea how to cook so because of that
making food and eating food it takes
super long right and then all that time
I could have used for like recording so
I started wearing an Apple watch because
I bought one because I'm rich then then
I realize I'd open one Apple watch
like I hate watches I hate wearing
watches it brings no value to me it's
pretty useless but I said to myself
maybe it's because I didn't buy the
latest version maybe that's why I think
it's useless like I didn't buy the Adam
s watch because of that it's useless so
I think the idea is that I had to spend
more money to make it useful but I am
trying to make use of it now but I'm
kind of embarrassed to say but like it's
an it's an apple it's an Apple watch 3
yeah I feel so ashamed saying it because
like it's an older generation no no I'm
sorry to disappoint you guys but like I
am trying to force myself to exercise
throughout this process because I know
that if you exercise then your brains
could be more sharp and if your brains
marché sharp you perform better in these
coding interviews right so I try to
complete those activity rings but I
realize these things are not very well
calibrated because um oh yeah for
example like one time I was in my room
and that was um I was watching
pornography and I was also jacking off
and by the way a jack off of my left
hand which is also the hand I put my
watch on oh yeah I jack off my left hand
because you know you can use it right
hand for the mouse so that I could skip
through videos so it makes more sense
yeah it was and then suddenly my watch
sends me this notification it said I see
you're working out do you want to record
this workout session I thought I was
doing the ellipticals you know like like
like that this
sighs right so I thought it was really
really funny cuz you know I thought it
was funny it's probably not that funny
for you guys but for me it was really
funny like you really had to be in the
moment to appreciate it
so basically what I end up doing is I
date I don't even need to exercise
because all I have to do is watch these
videos and I get my thirty minutes worth
of exercise done every day so I'm
basically cheating yeah so basically
coding it reminds me of it really
reminds me of school actually like
during finals season where you're just
at home sitting your room cramming
studying practicing it really reminds me
of that but I suck man I really suck
like I can do the easy problems I was
never good at brain teasers but yeah I
just got a grind anyways I just want to
update you guys on my life and what I'm
doing but yeah I mean I say all this
[ __ ] but in the end I kind of like it
right it's very nostalgic you know it's
it feels it feels nice like when you
finish problems when you do these
problems and you get it right it feels
like practicing for a math test or
something very nostalgic like basically
what I do is I do this Pomodoro style
thing right so like I saw one problem I
watch one episode of anime I solve one
problem i watch one episode I solve one
problem i watch five episode of anime to
finish the season if you're also like me
doing the coding interview process I
just want to say yeah don't give up it's
hard it's hard for everyone but it does
get easier and you know what they say
Ali Co today keeps the unemployment away
so see ya k2 tripping knuckle Phenom
suggest it
simple weapon on me